-Congratulations.
You have written,
you star in a Christmas film
You are in one of the most
beloved Christmas films
of all time, "Love Actually.
-Oh, yes.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're adding --
-I had forgotten.
-You're adding to the canon,
which is very nice.
You must like a Christmas film
-Yeah, I like some of them
-Yeah. That's true.
-I like some of them.
There's some real duds
out there.
-Yeah. Yeah, though, it's no
common to get a really good one.
But I did feel
we needed a new one.
-You did -- Okay,
so this was out of necessity
[ Laughter ]
-I think necessity
is putting it too strongly
-Yeah.
-Although I did need
to earn some money.
-Right, right.
[ Laughter ]
And that is what Christmas
is all about.
-Is all about, people.
Let's not forget.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't want skip over
a very interesting detail.
You wrote this film
with your husband.
-I did.
-And you've never written
a film together before.
-No.
-That must have been
a lovely experience.
-It was, and it was
accidental, as well,
because -- because
this wonderful producer
David Livingston said, "Do you
feel like writing a movie
based on George Michael's
Wham! song, 'Last Christmas'?"
And I said, "Not really."
[ Laughter ]
Because I'm not -- It's no
my favorite Christmas song
-Yeah.
-And, um,
it was a long time ago.
And I listened to it,
and I thought,
"Last Christmas,
you gave me your heart.
Then the very next day,
you gave it away.
And this year --"
What can I do that?
I can't think of a story.
So, I told my old man.
And we were on a walk
in the hills in Scotland.
And we thought, I wonder
if there's something else
we could do with it.
Could we come at it
at a different angle?
So, we started
dreaming up this idea.
You start with the idea,
which is like
a little piece of grit.
-Yeah.
-And then you have to
kind of pearlize the grit
over many years
with draft after draft
after draft, you know?
But the idea was good,
and it lasted.
And I met George Michael
about it
two years before he died.
And what a lovely guy.
-Yeah. And I will say, I -
Which is a thing
that I always regret,
I almost feel as though
I appreciated
exactly how lovely he was
after he passed away.
-I totally agree.
-You sort of hear the tributes
and you realize,
"Oh. I sort of saw you
through the prism
of your pop culture persona.
-Yeah.
-"And you were so much more --
There was so much more depth
to you than that."
-Yeah, he was
an extraordinary man.
I mean, really on the search
all his life
for a kind of authentic
way of being.
'Cause he hadn't come out
for a long, long time,
and that was really hard.
And his move from that
kind of Wham! music to --
Like, "Listen Without Prejudice"
is one of the greatest album
of all time, I think.
And I didn't realize --
It was really spooky.
I had no idea how pertinen
his lyrics, his poetry,
and his music were to the movi
and the story in the movie
until -- It was like
that late, late arrival
like you just described.
I just went, "Oh, my God.
This guy's really deep
and profound
and had very, very
great things to say
about what it is to be human
and how difficult it is
and how complicated it is.
-When you get a message like
that from the work you're --
You know, this is not
an adaptation of a song,
but the song is the inspiration,
somebody else's work.
When you get that from them,
are you so excited?
'Cause you're, like,
"Oh, my God.
They had given me more
than I even thought"?
Or do you have fear of, like
"Oh, I better not blow this,
'cause now this is more than
I thought it was going to be"?
-It happened over
such a long period of time
-How many years was it?
-Eight.
-Eight years?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-That you guys --
your marriage survived
working on an eight-year project
of any kind.
-Yeah. Absolutely.
It's extraordinary, isn't it
-That's the real
Christmas miracle.
-No, I mean, any long-term
relationship, yeah.
You just go,
"How is it possible?"
It's basically impossible,
actually.
So you just go --
Every moment that it lasts
you go, "Well,
this is kind of impossible
But it still seems to be here.
Wow, how fantastic."
And just keep
your fingers crossed.
-When did you shoot it?
Because there's so much
Christmas decorations
in the film.
Was it past Christmas?
Was it before? In real life,
when you were shooting it.
-Well, the fortunate thing was
that we were shooting in Londo
at night, before Christmas
three weeks before Christmas
Great. All great.
Everyone -- Okay.
We started at 2:00 A.M.,
so, in Covent Garden,
and it was magical, magical.
And everyone's, "Oh, guys, it'
Christmas. It's so gorgeous.
And then we had Christmas,
and we were thinking,
"This is great.
We get two weeks off
for Christmas,"
forgetting, of course,
that Christmas is so
unbelievably exhausting.
-Right.
-So, everyone came back
afterwards -- "Oh, I'm so tired.
It was a really [bleep]
Christmas.
I had a row with --
Long-term relationships
are impossible."
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then we had to carry o
doing Christmas.
-Yeah.
-Until February!
-Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that is
just a nightmare.
-A nightmare.
-You were that terrible neighbor
that doesn't take
their decorations down.
-Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
-In England, do --
Because we go from Halloween
and then we have a little bi
of a break with Thanksgiving
that you don't have.
Is it just pretty much
straight Christmas
from Halloween on over there
-From about July.
-Yeah, from July.
-Yeah, about then.
-You're a Christmassy culture?
-Terrible.
-Yeah.
-No, it's not -- I mean,
culture's just the wrong word.
When they start
selling Christmas,
they start selling it fast
and very early.
-They come right at you.
-Yeah, and I'm, like --
With our family,
I like Christmas,
because I had a nice childhood
-Uh-huh.
-So, I start sticking cloves
into fruit around November
And my husband, who did no
have a very nice childhood
really wants to be placed
into some medically induced coma
around December 15th
to January 1st.
-Yeah, just, like,
put on a drip or something
-So, talking of
long-term relationships,
it's taken 25 years.
You know how you get
a hedgehog to come in?
just open the back door
and leave a saucer of milk there
and hope that it finds --
-I'm going to pretend I do
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
It's a small mammal.
-Okay, yeah.
-We don't have any left,
of course,
because of climate change,
and Brexit, as well.
They all packed their little -
their little mammals rucksacks
-Yeah, oh, really?
-And -- Yeah, they just left
They said, "We don't
need to be here anymore."
-They were pro-stay.
-Yeah. "There won't be
any spare food.
And people will start
eating us again."
-It's interesting, 'cause
I was in Italy this summer
and there were so many
more hedgehogs than I --
-Yeah, just -- Yeah.
-They've emigrated.
-With their little packs.
-And they had British accents.
-They're gone, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Their little hedgehog passports.
[ Squeaking ]
-Which is hard for -- I feel bad
for the immigration people
'cause to me,
all hedgehogs look alike.
[ Laughter ]
-And their passports
are so tiny.
You have to have
those tiny stamps.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Squeaking ]
"There you go.
Bye. Enjoy France."
-You know what?
I'm going to end it here,
only 'cause I never want peopl
to find out
what your hedgehog analogy
was going to be.
I want them always to be like,
they got so sidetracked
that we never knew
why Emma was saying,
"You know how you lure in
hedgehogs with water?
And you've got your mallet
Anyway --"
[ Laughter ]
That's Emma Thompson, everybody.